it's terrifying absolutely terrifying
you one of the most terrifying moments
I've ever experienced guy I I may have
wet the bed yeah and your my pants ah
already I'm already feeling things no
nope nope not watching that hey you
you're supposed to give me some baby
where's that busy we're talking about
baby here like I really thought it was
live circuit if I went pee in the toilet
it would bite my big dick off that next
time you sit on me I'm gonna bite off
your touching creature of Darkness come
to me who are you talking to
oh yeah I remember that
cool this kids not a good actor I can
now see that
oh boy it's just so haunting it's like a
horrifying story about a terrible car
accident is that kid appropriate I don't
maybe that oh my god oh my god
Kevin's hair looks great that's exactly
how my hair look like as a kid okay so
this is scary it's only my imagination I
hate this
oh that's disgusting somebody dudes up
oh just to be squeezed immediately
before she explodes explodes this is
real life this could happen to me
clearly it was still kind of like creepy
it was really dark if I had children I
would probably show this to them just to
see what the effect would be on them I
would show it to my own children this is
a moment that will scare them purely for
the joy of being scared and we just
don't have that anymore I don't think
it's doing anyone any favors to like
scrub the grime off of movies because
life has some grime on it there's just
that movies like that anymore